I'm having a hard time thinking of a
more anti veteran anti-military
presidential candidate the Donald Trump
he's ridiculed John McCain for having
been a prisoner of war during his
military service Trump is made it
abundantly clear through this very odd
pattern of non donations and then very
conspicuous donations to veterans groups
that he sees donating to veterans merely
as a political tool to be used as needed
for his campaign Donald Trump may be one
of the most indifferent to veteran
candidates that I can recall most
recently Donald Trump yesterday
suggested to a room full of veterans
that soldiers who come back from war
suffering with PTSD are not strong and
just couldn't handle it this is
something that Donald Trump said during
a Q&A at what's called the retired
American warriors pack political action
committee some of the questions were
about the suicide epidemic in the
military some of them were critiques of
the Veterans Administration Veterans
Affairs administration for falling short
on providing veterans with the mental
health that they need and I'm in a play
for you what Donald Trump said when
asked about the issue of suicide and
PTSD and it's absolutely deplorable I
mean did this should uniquely and
singularly make it so that not a single
veteran or anyone who cares about
veterans votes for Donald Trump listened
to what he had to say when you talk
about the mental health problems when
people come back from war in combat and
they see things that maybe a lot of the
folks in this room have seen many times
over and you're strong and you can
handle it but a lot of people can't
handle it and they see horror stories
they see events that you couldn't see in
a movie nobody would believe it now we
need a mental health help and medical
yeah we need a mental health help and
medical seriously though it's all about
some soldiers are just strong enough and
some soldiers are what does that mean
well clear thinking veterans are not
happy with Trump John Soltes who's a
veteran of the Iraq
or and chairman of the vote vets
organization said that Trump's remarks
are both horrible but not shocking
clearly trumpets at the bar very very
low during his campaign uh going on to
say quote we're talking about a person
in Trump who believes that POWs aren't
real heroes of course referencing Donald
Trump's comments about Senator John
McCain uh we interviewed will Fisher
yesterday on the program and he went on
to say uh he is an Iraq war veteran he
is a Purple Heart recipient and he told
BuzzFeed news about these comments
Trump's comments about veterans with
PTSD reveal his total disdain for
veterans and military families and
highlight just how disconnected he is
with our community I miss the good old
days when saying something like forty
seven percent of Americans are takers
was enough to sink your campaign for
good as it happened to Mitt Romney in
2016 apparently you can say and Trump
has said any number of heinous ly
offensive things about groups that
presumably we care about right uh uh uh
women veterans LGBT individuals people
who may be of a different religion or
ethnicity you can basically say whatever
you want and it doesn't end your
campaign and that is incredibly
disturbing